and the spirit award for best
cinematography goes to
bust it up
bust it up
edu growl for passing
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this doesn't move okay great
it's going great guys it's going great
we are in the commercial break and yes
okay so um
means a lot to be recognized here
tonight
today
by a community of filmmakers i totally
admire
thank you fellow nominees you you are
people i totally respect
seeing you tonight it reminds me of the
importance of what we do
we are not heroes like nurses or doctors
or teachers
we just make movies
but our work can create debate open
people's minds and give a point of view
to the world
what we do what we say
and how we say it it is important
thank you rebecca for telling this story
with light
for believing for 10 years that passing
a marvelous 1920s noble deserve a film
like ours
thank you margot
thank you nina
forest channel 4 and netflix for making
one of those films that are rare to find
these days
thank you to my crew for never stop
believing what the story that the story
were telling was important
but
we will not be here without our families
our partners in crime
they sacrifice a lot for us to be able
to make movies
mighty
your love is the most beautiful thing
that has happened to me i learned from
your endurance your intelligence and
team playing every single day of my life
on monday
we had our second daughter
you know how hard it's been to get here
it was a miracle and i cannot imagine
what it would mean for us to be running
away from our homes like the ukrainians
that are what were right now
my thoughts are with all of them
thank you guys
and please keep making good movies
keep making movies that make this a
better world thank you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you